for one time finally somebody knows what
the gift you get to you get to be next
to him all the it's a gift right it's
like being with a human and a pet at the
same time you know what I mean it's like
you got it's like it's this is your
place and then there's cats here and
then you got Bobby yeah right and you
got and he's like a little pet that's
cool um let's start from the beginning
can we start from the beginning
or okay why do you all right first of
all can I just say this why do you think
that you know that I'm not Chinese right
right what am I you're Korean all right
so but how come for the last 25 years
every time I see your [__] eyes look
super Chinese dude I don't know what to
say they do I mean that's that's a good
observation yeah very good observation
yeah you're you're more like Filipino W
so you know the variety you know the
variety so you wouldn't call him Chinese
no only me I look Chinese cuz of my eyes
um yeah I mean you look you know you
look very Asian
Asian I am very Asian yeah he doesn't
look as as Asian yeah but like since
I've known you when you bring me up on
stage you always go Chinese people all
that kind of stuff I stopped doing that
I know but you did it at the spa the
other night I can't help
it we go to the Korean spa there's a
bunch of Koreans S standing around and I
don't even plan to meet Paul there I
just run into him in there right and I
won't even know he's there I'm taking a
shower and then I'll all of a I'll hear
Chinese people are the luckiest people
in the world the luckiest are the luest
we are the luckiest and then I'll turn
around and I'll have a panic attack oh
my God he's here he's here he's here
right no what happens is is you know
we're in this life of ours you know what
I mean we're all going through different
things like you know stress and [__]
like bobby gets depressed you know what
I mean we all get depressed we get sad
and stuff like that and the Asian spa
the Korean spa is the only place that
Bobby can go to feel really comfortable
and feel really like oh I can finally
let let go yeah you know I'm not around
anyone not around my agents my girl no
movies no TV I can just be here by
myself and he goes in there and he's
scrubbing his little [__]
vagina looks like a [__] vagina so
[__] yeah you know yeah could you see
that right and I scream I scream I get
so excited I'm like I found the it's
like I cornered the animal you know what
I mean I cornered him and I scream I'm
like Chinese Chinese
baby yeah and he just like [__] gets
his whole face gets sad he qu and then
literally he makes the spa his like
within he does it really quick 3 minutes
and he leaves you know what I mean cuz
you can't really enjoy yourself knowing
that I'm there yeah you do feel that
then yeah of
course cuz I always think I'm being slly
no I got to
go no I know you don't want I know you
don't want want be there with you know I
love you but you don't go in the cold
you don't go into the you don't go into
the hot you just do the yeah I do the
your steam room and then I go to the
cold punch and I leave yeah every time
but um I love it there because I love to
be able you know I see them and and and
half of them I'd say I've been going
there for so long I actually have a pass
yeah you bought a pass I think I'm the
only white person that has a pass like a
onee pass you can pay $900 and you can
go all the time yeah and then you I'm
Jewish so I start doing the math I'm
like is it worth it how many times a
week do I go here and I go probably
about five times a week damn wow you do
I was there today of course it's the
best right because it's lowkey yeah the
steam room is super hot yeah and um you
love Asian people obsessed yes so it's
like everything in one me yeah yeah yeah
and uh and the lady's so mean at the
front which we love I love that yeah
yeah what do you mean she's so mean
she's so mean she's so [__] mean the
they won't even look at you sometimes
they'll just go and they'll throw you
the key mhm like like you're garbage oh
I love it yeah yeah and then there was
like a sort of a sex thing going on
there yeah but did you ever figure that
out or no I tried to because the chicks
were [__] hot yeah yeah but then like
they wouldn't let any white people in
there at all someone wrote in and said
that her brother was actually part of I
don't want to put him out but he was
part of the vice squad that um busted
them and it was some type of what you
guys were talking about it was they
would karaoke but it wasn't it was
there's no 40 Asian and white Chi out of
aoke yeah hot I Tred to get in there I
remember one night you go how do you do
it and they're like no no no not for you
yeah yeah not for you I got a pass
though not called your dick i' be like
little Stevie coming to get little baby
Bobby dude you know I mean yeah but uh
remember that one time we were in um
Michigan or something and you go we're
sharing the same bed hotel room yeah
that wasn't cool dude I'm still mad at
you for that no cuz basically when
you're on the road you're on the bus and
then you and then you pull over and
everyone goes to their hotel room that's
just you know you check in you here's
your key blah blah blah and I was like I
don't want to say I was lonely but I
didn't I'm always going to my hotel room
by myself and it was Detroit and it was
[__] creepy and our hotel was next to
a [__] uh like a grave grave site
right yeah [__] it was gnarly Detroit
[__] gnarly cuz we were playing at at
chaplain which is on the outside of
Detroit which is like this Comedy Club
connected to a bowling out it's [__]
gnarly dude like really gnarly my checks
bounced from there all the time all the
time you know what I mean and after you
know we we get a thing all a sudden I
knock on Bobby's door and he's like
looks and he's like what do you want and
I'm like dude I want to stay with you
you know let me stay in your room with
you and you're like no no no no no I
don't want to and I'm like I'm like no
for real I want to stay and he's like
you're kidding right he goes you got
your own sweet dude and I'm like I know
but I want to stay next to you I go and
I look in his room he's got two beds
yeah he doesn't I'm like let me just
stay in the extra
bed let me just take the bed and he you
know and literally I'm like dude goes
you're [__] serious I go yeah I'm
serious I want to be next to you and we
can watch TV and just chill and talk as
a friend you know what I mean so I Jimmy
my way in the room I Jimmy my way in the
room and he literally curls on the floor
and starts crying like he starts crying
like for real for real cuz he really
like didn't want to be next to me it's
devastating yeah cuz that would mean
that I'm not going to get any sleep okay
cuz I my now I have to see what he's
going to do one Chinese eyes is open
right the whole
time I can't see you yeah the Chinese
side and I literally started crying and
then he got mad he was like I'm going to
go to my room he went back to his room
made a really terrible sleep well that's
my fault you have you know mean you make
money you should have your own room I
it's weird no I companionship yeah I
just wanted to hang with with my friend
you don't know what he's like he
scratches my skin but not in a friendly
way like he tries to get into the skin
with his
claws my
claws little baby little
baby love see that's the thing is is
that our our relationship hasn't changed
no it's it's got more [__] up it's
more [__] up and complex you know what
I mean but I can't believe we haven't
had you on
earlier that's my bad I Can't Believe
It's Not
Butter yeah you know how your name came
came up though Rosie did it last week he
did oh my one of my best friends I know
Rosie did it he's like have you had I go
I don't know why I never even asked him
it's okay bud I'm honored honored to be
here it's a real honor thank you always
an honor to do anything with the kid
yeah hell yeah
bro
bro we could we we haven't started yet
no go 5 4 three wait wait stop before
you even go um before keep it rolling
but
um don't say anything till I bring up
say your
name 5 4 3 2 1 yeah hello
uhhuh that's
right no no I keep I do it the way I
want to do it okay hello what's up uhhuh
welcome my name is m
welcome to the
celebration celebration of
life
yeah keep going keep
going
[Music]
cation okay stop yep stop welcome to
episode number something how number 300
two not two something in the hundreds in
the hundreds welcome to this one this is
a celebratory uh uh event tonight
evening we've got uh me I'm great I'm
wonderful I you know I look in the
mirror I go that's the way it is and
that's it really that is the way it is
and that's the way um it's going to be
okay no don't say anything yet okay
we've got my beautiful little lotus
flower here from the Philippine Islands
Lo of flow or Lotus Loa Lo of flow yeah
non-existent we beautiful though she's
great she's got milky skin she's got wet
hands right and she's Mo moist but her
brain is the most important thing she's
very smart she's bright she's a bright
girl she's a bright girl and she has an
education and it's unfuckin believable
college she went to college and our
minds when we Mel dude it's like [__]
simple but great I learn we got right
here we got um just I you know I keep
calling you flat no harand not yet
okay we got got right here we got uh the
brownest face from this side of Tiki
Island thank you so much yeah yeah John
John what's your name Gilbert oh Gilbert
gandz galendez yeah whatever and then
we've got right here [__] serial killer
101 right here dude not only does he
kill he skins the [__] dick skin off
and [__] makes it a helmet oh puts it
on his own thing and we got a stupid
stupid stupid stupid stupid stupid
stupid stupid stupid stupid cousin right
here welcome to the show we have a very
[__] great guest man I can't even
believe we this guy is a has a doctorate
in metaphysics yep um he he makes dream
catchers out of dilithium crystals and
adamantium steel wow two elements that
you can't really even find on this
planet nope right he's uh written poetry
right a couple of books am I not right
yeah a couple of books both of them are
about physiology and the mind and the
third one's about the history of before
preindustrial Revolution
very only in Vermont though specifically
specifically in Vermont this guy right
here man makes maple syrup out of just
pine
trees oh he can get he invented a
machine to make [__] maple syrup out
of pine trees right he's a doctor
doctorate Humphrey mcgiven Stevens is
here give him
that's here I'm fre hello you Dr Lee
excuse me Dr Lee thank you how are you
thank you talk about your books okay
well the first one I published in
1983 spent many years doing research up
in Berkeley yes and uh some of the
findings were just uh you know just
unbelievable they were groundbreaking
and uh and the book inspired many other
people to come behind me and continue
the research I stepped back yeah yeah
and uh we opened a wing at uh Berkeley
and uh what's the wing called uh
barbecue and oh you did the barbecue
Wing wow the barbecue Wing in Berkeley
yeah that's amazing and uh and the
research is ongoing so the book was a
real hit was the book called again I
forgot it didn't say on Wikipedia oh you
you said it earlier yeah my findings on
Earth yeah yeah that's was that your
first one yeah my findings on Earth yeah
right and the second one was second one
was inchworms why are they 2 in long
yeah yeah what they're lying they're
lying they're they are lying do you
think they are I think they're longer
than an inch right and my research shows
they are they are yeah yeah that's
that's unbelievable that was a great
book do you like insects I do I like
praying mantises the most because when
you take them hostage they pray you know
the other insects just sit there and
look like [__]
tards praying metis just will pray
before you stomp on them sometimes I'll
let them go cuz they they pray do you
have a wallet I do what do you use uh uh
my wallet yeah yeah let me see uh okay
[Laughter]
okay it's a leather it's leather used to
be Iron Man I used to have an Iron Man
wallet but at War out this is pretty new
it's pretty nice though huh yeah keep my
ID in
here may I see it you really yeah yeah
may I see your ID sure yeah f the
damn is that here we go my driver's
license whatever let me
[Music]
see what is it well it's not driver is a
UFO operator's
license it says
Alon Alon look at it says under sex
under sex it says
yes under six yes height
32 yeah uh weight
35 hair naan eyes black it expired my oh
331 it expired fantastic 2001 it
expired well that's great so you're you
can operate a UFO pretty much yeah can
you no I don't I've never even been one
stick around kid and then here's another
thing they're garbage as my yeah you get
it um you also did a special I I I don't
know if this is right or not in front of
in the forest no I did it in the desert
right right where we shot remember we
shot behind a great big hill in the
desert yeah so I owned that Hill I
bought that Hill you could buy Hill wa
wait you bought a hill in the desert
yeah we shot we shot on my land didn't I
tell you that was my land we were
shooting on oh I did not know that I
bought 20 acres in the middle of the
desert
10 of it is a giant Hill and so I went
back a few years later and I shot my
standup comedy special up on the hill in
the middle of the desert whoa yeah who
was there no one it was just me and I
had a tortoise a friend of mine out of
tortoise so it was walking around it was
a walking around this is amazing while I
did my stand up and a couple while I was
doing my standup a couple of wild dogs
there's a lot of wild dogs out there two
wild dogs walked right through my set
well I they just wandered through and I
talked to them and then they wandered
off into the desert it was fantastic aw
I had a crew had like we had a seven
seven cameras and a jib and a crane and
we even had a helicopter we had a
helicopter flying around shooting it
yeah this was you know and and it was
amazing and yeah but how do you do I
mean how do you with the laughs did you
put in laughs later no nothing I just I
just I just heard them in my head you
know it's a it's an act that I worked
on it's an act I worked on for many
years and and I just knew the timing so
well that I just in as I was doing it I
just accounted for the laughs in my I
pretended I could hear them wow so if
you're watching the this thing yeah you
don't hear any laughs you just hear just
silence silence and it's beautiful you
don't like the comedy the view is
beautiful it really is yeah cuz there's
nothing El there you can just see
forever
it's beautiful stunning and then you um
is it an hour long yeah wow that kind of
I watched one of my favorite shows is
called Mozart in the jungle and he goes
through like an artistic block as a
compos he's not a composer he's a
maastro and one of the things to break
his artistic block was to perform solely
for himself and without the Roar of the
crowd that he was used to beautiful and
he was able to elevate himself and elev
his practice which is sort of that's
what they wanted to bring a crowd in and
I wouldn't let them they wanted to bust
like people out and build like like
seats around me and I said no you're
missing the point this is this is about
me like doing standup out to the
universe it's out out to the world it's
not it's not for there can't be any bar
there can't be a wall of people it's got
to it's got to go out to everything wow
so it's very Spirit you also eliminate
the ego from the performance aspect of
it it was just it was just me yelling
out there was no barriers there's no
walls there's no curtains there was no
roofs it was just wow improvise at all
out there I did WOW but I did my ACT but
there was a lot like like I had to
improvise the dogs right and then that
was a crowd work that was amazing and
there was a there was like some birds
flew by and were like ah and I pretended
they were heckling me wow and then at
one point three guys in motorized hang
gliders buzzed right over and I just
started yelling at them screaming wow
yeah it was really really fun yeah it's
called the force of nature harlon
Williams a force of nature website or
could we that's the same thing on my
website it's it's DV let's let's do
truth talk you like truth talks oh come
on man you I just gave let's do another
come on pain medic got godamn stitching
I can't really get into a physical
[__] banter with you phys I'm doing
truth I can't believe you're here yeah
but that's because I love this guy no I
said you want to cancel and you're like
no right if I had a deadly poison in my
dick okay I'm in
Uganda right I'm going hey guys I'm
going to take a leak in the desert yeah
what do you do pull over right so I go
into the desert right pull my little
dick out right and all a I you know what
I mean some I go what is that right I
turn around and it's like a mambo like
one of those black Mambo m m whatever
those are right and he goes what's up he
goes what's up I go and he bites my dick
right and I have a poison on my dick and
you're the only one with me would you
suck the poison out of my dick
yes yes thank you just look up what do
you mean like don't look at me when I'm
doing that's the only way Bobby does it
though that's the only way right right
right look up right but that's not what
I would be doing here are the things
that I have to do I've had my dick you
want eye to eye I've had my dick right
bit by before and somebody sucked it out
so what I need to do I need to grab the
back of your head right because I need
you I need all the poison St out so I
just need to control it a bit right I
need to look down because a bite mark is
kind of like a scratch Mark like when
you ask someone to scratch they don't
know exactly where they're just randomly
scratching so you have to guide the hand
there we go you don't know where the
poison they don't know where the poison
is that's exactly what I'm say the
poison and I also need to lock eyes with
you you have to look up and I have to
look down and I have to give you a
wink I do I'll get the poison out oh
thank you I know you would like you you
do like to say what's on your mind you
do don't [__] give me that look
[__] there's a bunch of words you
said before this [__] show started
have to edit y yeah we do don't we do we
not do we not have to edit a bunch of
words okay I want to say this okay do we
not have to edit a bunch of words before
you want to talk about you want to talk
about [__] that was said before we even
started this thing no I will tell you
something right now I know but I'm going
to tell you something right now dude all
right I say [__] up things like that
so I don't say it on the podcast so I
can just get it
out Purge I'm purging it all right got
it God all right God
man yeah people camera is that my camera
yeah
yeah like you know like people are
getting like I I'll be on stage and I'll
go um hey what are you like guy in front
he go yeah I'm Filipino I go yeah you're
Asian then no I'm Filipino I'm a Pacific
island we're different what are you so
people want to like now change the rules
right and the rules is this
okay if you have I don't know what the
rules are actually I don't know the
rules it's very easy the Philipp sits
philippin sits two hours away from Japan
there we go Japan's in the heart of Asia
right which means you're [__] Asian
you're in Asia it's the reason it's
called southeast Asia because it's Asia
that's what I wanted that's the
information I want you need just because
there's like cross culture stuff
happening doesn't mean that
geographically we're not a part of Asia
because we are right and if I say were
the Asians at and you're Indian and you
don't raise your hand or any or make a
sound go [__] yourself because hey
Indians you're Asia too yeah you are and
you know what there's some Russians that
look Asian hell yeah that their country
goes into China yeah they're I saw I saw
a Russian fighter and I swear to God at
the end of the fight I was I didn't know
who he was I know and I was like this
this a Chinese fighter right he had very
pale skin his eyes were very almond I
was like and then they were like he's
from blah blah blah glit CL
yeah love that City for a second there I
thought that was an Asian man to me like
when um borak came out I Googled what
people from Kazakhstan look like
Kazakhstan as that's what it was it was
Kazakhstan mhm is that a real thing why
didn't you say that earlier no is it I
think that's where the I think that's
where the fire fighter was from yeah
they all look right kind of Chinese yes
crazy yeah it's crazy man yeah and they
all look like you know like if you look
at people from the border of China and
Russia like if people that live in those
like little towns they all look like Bor
yeah you're not wrong but they kind of
do so right yeah I was actually going to
say that they that's where bork's from
that EUR Asian yeah or Rob Schneider
like Bor Rob Schneider does not look
Russian Rob or bork but even in the
Philippines same how the [__] do you get
I'm sorry go ahead put an [__] that
was weird yeah that was weird likeo I'm
kidding I was just throwing it out I
don't know why you know here's the thing
guys um I say things that aren't
necessarily funny or not necessarily um
relevant or it might even have anything
to do with what we're talking about but
um I throw it out there it pops in my
head I don't have a filter I just say it
and I'll cut that part out Rob schider
not mark
it Mark Mark the mark rub shedder he's
going to do our podcast soon okay what
I'm saying to you is is that when I
start the podcast have you started it
now no I haven't no okay cuz he's going
to do the countdown mhm so don't say
anything until I say your name because I
got to say welcome this and that and all
that stuff do but it annoys me in the
comedy world you know that you saying to
me don't say anything basically is
saying say something you have to you you
must I know in the comedy world that
that's real but this is not the comedy
world but it literally is it literally
isn't it literally isn't and the thing
is is that
I'm I'm being it's actually the only
thing this
is this is not anything else all right
all right George you're this close to
getting kicked out of the room all right
I'm being [__] real dude I I'm being
[__] real right now you're really
pissing me off by cackling like that
like a hyena all right and you too
Gilbert Sor I'm being real all right and
this is really pissing me off right now
dude I want to see this right now
promise I cut my mic then no it's not
cut the mic all right I'm telling you
right now if you even if I hear a
[__] breath out of you right before I
introduce your name I will literally
shut it down I don't give a [__] cuz we
this is a backlogged one any we know
this doesn't come out for two weeks I'll
get Craig Fergus somebody else to
[__] do it all right I'll get Ali
Wong or something to do it all right so
what I'm saying to you right now you're
going to threaten me with [__] Ali
Wong no no no don't I'm just kidding it
was a joke all right go so all right
thank you do it 5 4 3 two one beautiful
day it really is to me yeah yeah it's
it's a beautiful day it really is to me
yeah yeah walking down the path seeing
the flower seeing the bues fly on my
head walking down the street with me and
you holding each other doing it right
[Music]
doing welcome to welcome to another
episode one more
time oh my God what was the
inspiration I just made it up it was so
good I love it it's a hit it's a [__]
hit I said something so mean to my wife
before I left GH what' you say I'm I was
being mean what' you say very mean you
said something mean I said something
mean what is it I I don't want to say it
I said something mean okay okay okay I
said she was a fat piece of dog
[__] no I just got mad because I I am I
am a I'm this guy this is this is me
this is literally me right um you're her
ask me uh you've just walked in and say
hey did you end up um asking your mom
about that Christmas ornament thing we
needed okay this and I'm watching a
YouTu compliment K that's a PR all right
and and I'm watching the and I'm
watching a YouTube line bab a a YouTube
video I'm watching a YouTube video I
hope you get it right on the couch okay
can I say action yeah go okay roll
cameras and action hey uh babe did you
ask your mom about that Christmas
ornament thing that we needed what what
what that Christmas ornament thing that
said
what what it's a simple question okay
stop stop stop stop that's what I do
right away did I did I not do that the
other night with the
cougar which cougar Red Dead Redemption
in Red Dead Redemption oh yeah yeah yeah
I get so so that's my problem you get
interrupted then I snap okay you see me
on the goddamn [__] phone yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm in it I'm inside
of it so I'm going to tell you something
what happened the other night I lost my
[__] okay I'm going to tell you
something you take your [__] hold on
second I want to know what you said yeah
besides just snapping in that way show
you something oh my
God babe I will show you something right
now must have seen Andrew
smile that's you wait hold on leave it
leave it one more time hold on hold on
real quick real quick real quick real
quick what is well for people that are
on audio uh something get in get in get
in boom
boom walking down the street me and my
friend okay so I don't have any I don't
I don't have any patience I have no
patience when I'm on the when I'm on the
phone I'm doing a thing just let me
finish the thing as soon as I'm done
I'll get right back to you I promise but
she does it and she knows she does it
and then I
just I lose it I am a [__] [__]
and you know what gets me even more mad
I imagine our neighbors are going that
guy's a [__] [__] cuz they never
hear her right they just hear me yelling
and I've never hit
her I know you haven't never never never
yeah you thought about it though
m
so I'm playing I'm playing Red Dead
Redemption yeah video game the new one
the new one yeah it's so good huh so one
of the the little goals is to kill five
cougars not easy with a bow and
arrow finding a cougar is like running
into in real life an Eskimo sure let me
ask you something how many Eskimos have
you ran into in your whole life honestly
zero exactly and I had to kill five of
them you have to find them in the game
and kill them yeah and they're very rare
yeah right yeah I finally have one I've
been looking for three hours got one I I
pull back on my bone arrow right and
this is right here sweetie I turn like
this and I go back to the screen the he
had hit my neck the
cougar and eyes roll back and I fall to
the ground and I die and I look at I go
what and then she starts crying I didn't
cry a little bit you were so upset like
I can't I don't know when to say
anything you know what I mean well okay
and I'm like this is this wasn't a short
YouTube video this is a 16h hour a day
game so I don't know when to interject
did you know that the cougar was there
no yeah but now you
know right so then right and then what
she was going to interrupt me for was
this is what she was going to say she
was had a snaggle too no Julio and Bojo
are getting along better oh yeah the cat
so my younger cat cats are now not one
of my dogs is getting along better and
you know when you think about it that's
that's the information I really needed
to hear that V think about okay so our
our our [__] dog and our shy cat were
now kissing they're kissing and it was
such a rare moment that I had to tell
him in that moment oh my God turn around
look at the animals they getting Al but
then meanwhile you know what I mean I
got one and yeah yeah done and then
here's what was worse the 3 hours after
that me walking around trying to find
C you didn't see all that and me trying
to breathe hard to let you know yeah
like you know what I mean and
out trying to like bring you I I I and
then at 5: in the morning I found one
but it was um not pristine coat um but
still I got the thing but I wanted the
coat to make a jacket but anyway what
pristine coat oh oh oh the level of the
cougar the level of the cougar has to be
the right level to WR the right you know
coat yeah yeah but anyway um so I get
what you're saying yeah